I need to I don't know. I don't know. I
need to
I need to you know learn. Okay. So So
you know you know as a Muslim we say the
logical rational argument why there is
God
yourself you're proof for God's
existence cuz the question who gave you
life?
Who gave you who gave you life?
Read John 3:16. So your Bible you're a
Christian. Yeah I I went to church. So
you atheist or a Christian?
I went to church though. You know I know
the values. I know the values. Okay.
That's the most important part of it.
But the brother was telling me you're an
atheist. That's why I'm got confused.
Yeah. I know. Obviously I went to
church. He taught me the values but I
just through going you know smoking weed
and stuff. Yeah. You get it? So you just
left that. You're just in middle in the
middle type of thing. No but I mean like
I went that for that lifestyle. This is
the first time speak.
It's your first time here. Yeah. Yeah.
Oh, that's why you're surprised to see
cameras everywhere cuz it's the nature
of speakers. Welcome speakers now. You
know, when people just have
conversation, they record them. So, I
mean like I I went for that lifestyle as
well. I started smoking back in the days
when I was young. I'm still young. You
get me? But pay pay attention. Look at
the cameras anyway. Listen carefully,
brother. What I'm saying? God's
existence is savag rooted within us.
It's clear. You know the universe
itself, your stuff is a proof for God's
existence.
You're great. I've seen on YouTube and
you're brilliant. After all this, right,
if you can take a picture with you,
[Music]
what we say to you, look, what we say to
you, yourself and everything here is a
proof of God's existence. Cuz it's
illogical for this beautiful creation to
come without any creator. Then there's
another one. You must have a creator and
we must have a purpose. Every part of
your body have a purpose. What about you
as a whole? What is your purpose in this
life?
Money. That's not our purpose. That's
not our purpose. Man, that's our
purpose. Money will not That's what I
was going to say. When you die, money is
going to benefit you. I mean to show you
the money is nothing. When the people
died, our when the people when there's a
drought and Why didn't the billionaires
give away the money then? This was it.
Why billionaire billionaires? They give
away their money. All of them. No, you
have I mean they have to give you money.
Sure you're not happy. But how many
people who are billionaires commit
suicide cuz they not happy. It's true.
So if the money is a sign of the money
doesn't mean look let me make something
clear. It's good to have money of course
will help you with your life. But the
money does not give you the ultimate
happiness. You understand? It give you
that temporary happiness. It helps you
with your life. Like our prophet said
it's better to be rich than to be poor.
Because when you're poor, you you're
right on other people. You understand?
So being rich and and the prophet
Muhammad taught us there have people you
should be jealous of which good jealousy
not bad jealousy. Someone who Allah gave
him a lot of money and he spend it in
the way of Allah and he takes care of
people. He looks after orphans, the poor
people. So don't get me wrong, having
good money is good. Pro said that to
advise one of his companions when he's
about to die. He was rich. He said,
"Don't give your money away. Let your
children to have it." You understand? Of
course, you can give it away as as a
donation some of it. All right? So, why
we say to you, we're not here for for
for money. We are here for a greater
purpose. We are here to worship the
creator. You know, this life is a test.
God put us here to test us. God will
test us different ways. I mean, as a
Christian, you know that from the Bible
as well. In the Bible, there's very
similar things about this life is a
test. God's going to test us. Like we
believe in Jesus, Moses, Abraham, Noah,
Jacob, Isaac, Ishmael, and the last of
them we believe in the prophet Muhammad
because we believe the Bible has been
corrupted by the Romans. What part of
the Bible though? What part? I'll tell
you. If you go Matthew 17:21
is not in the New King James, not New
King James, in ESV, NIV. They tell you
because it's been it's been added. It
was someone made it up. Someone made it
up. Yeah. So, if you have King James, go
back home. Remember this. Go home, put
King James, put NIV, ESV. Go Matthew
17:21. It's in King James, but it's not
in NIV or ESV. So what do you So what do
you think is going to happen on judgment
day then? So that day of judgment, Allah
subhana wa ta'ala taught us there's no
one knows what is going to happen in day
of judgment in detail like the Muslims.
The Bible doesn't speak about it in
detail. The Islam, so we believe there's
three uh stages in life. There's this
life and there's the life of the grave.
The life of the grave. When we die when
So when we die now, where will we go
now? That's it. So when you die, we call
life of the grave. We call it
al mean a barrier between this life and
here after the angels, two angels will
come to you and ask about your belief
system. Who is your lord? What is your
religion? If your religion is a man,
you're going to say is a money. But they
will not help you before God. God
doesn't care about your money. If you
are if you meaning that not because you
have money God you're going to God is
going to be happy with you you know so
likewise what do you think about the man
that was sent to you the prophet
Muhammad from Cameroon brother okay you
know from Israel Jesus was sent to the
Israel to the Israelites why was when
the woman came to him she was a canonite
and she said to him she was asking him
for help but Mary was a Jewish woman
wasn't she that's her background not
believe cuz there's no there's no
something called Jewish belief in
reality cuz even Moses if you go to the
Torah he never said my belief is a
Judaism you understand Judah came after
okay so mean after Isaac and and and
Jacob and yeah Judah was a son of Jacob
but my point here is that when the woman
was asking Jesus for help he said I was
only sent to the lost house sheep of
Israel okay then there's a passage yes
when Jesus said go spread uh the message
around the world. But if you look if you
go back to it in the Greek language
which I took this benefit from the
Hebrew Israelites you know you know
that's why it's good to hear both sides
they said if you go n is around the
world you understand but in the Quran
clearly prophet Muhammad will send to
everyone you understand let me give you
example to understand my point here
imagine in your own house and there's a
fire everywhere you wake up in your own
room and there's fire everywhere and you
try your best to serve yourself and you
couldn't you gave up. You thought, you
know, it's over and I came and I saved
your life. What would you say to me at
least?
Would you remember me all the time? So,
why don't you thank and remember God who
gave you life for free.
I never gave your life, but you said you
would thank me. You remember me. You
see, so you have something is so dear to
you. You do everything to protect it and
to save it. God gave it to you for free.
You know while we speaking we are
benefited from God's blessings oxygen
the air in out may Allah forbid if one
of us go to the hospital way okay cool
so what are you going to say let me
finish this question let me finish what
I will tell you if one of us go to the
hospital and they have to give you
oxygen they will charge you for it has
given it to you for free understand as
for your question where the Christians
going to go to then the true followers
of Jesus who truly followed the teaching
of Jesus before the sending of the
prophet Muhammad They go to paradise. As
for the Muslims, yeah, the true
followers Jesus, the Muslims in fact,
you call them Muslims, you call them
nas. Okay. But after the sending prophet
Muhammad, the Christians that knew about
Prophet Muhammad about Islam and they
turned away from Islam, they will go to
the hellfire forever. Yeah. So go to
hell. Not all of them. Like I just
explained to you, but they're not
Muslim. Okay. I explain to you the those
Jewish people who never believe in
Jesus, where they going to go to
according to Christianity.
hell. All right. You see, thank you for
having me on this. That's it. Likewise,
but the the Jewish that believe in Moses
before Jesus correctly, they go to
paradise. But after the sending of Jesus
is the the Jewish people must follow
Jesus teaching. Likewise, after Allah
sent the prophet Muhammad, mankind must
follow this prophet because he came with
the same teaching. However, he came with
the legislation is eternal. meaning for
all the times like when you the Bible I
mean like you can see Christianity is
dying in the western world you from
Africa I'm from Africa the French came
to my country and they tried to force
Christianity on us for 132 years my
father was in prison for 10 years and
they enslaved him in prison may Allah
have mercy upon the French and he never
never turned away from his dean
alhamdulillah you know my father was muj
Allah have mercy upon him so the
European brought Christianity to us in
Africa and they forc us to accept
Christianity a person might say but
Muslim is is not because when when
prophet Muhammad wasallam starts his
message the Roman basantine start
attacking the Muslims first and North
Africa and many place in Africa was part
of the empire of the Roman Empire you
understand so they started the war see
they start the war like North Africa of
it all right this man is supporting the
children what do you think about the
what do you think about Natalyah who's
killing the children what do you think
about
Natal support him So don't listen to me.
Support him. Anyway, what I'm going to
say to you, okay, cool. So, okay. So,
we've got the whole Gaza situation. The
whole Gaza situation. Yeah. So, so
they're wrong. Who's wrong? Zion is
wrong. The invaders, of course. The
Zionist invaded. If they stop. So, if
they stop today, that mean the war will
stop. No, no, not like that. If that was
the only thing, right? If the world mean
no the mid middle east will be m look
the reason look America they said it Joe
Biden before he became president he said
even if there was no Israel we will
create Israel just to destabilize the
Middle East there two countries were
made by one by the French and why
America the French it was the sh
government by was namei he was he was in
France and the French helped him to take
over Iran and Israel was helped by
America and Britain
to destabilize the Middle East, the Arab
walls. You understand? So, so I'm not
telling you if they stop the war in in
Gaza, everyone going to stop. No, cuz
this life is a test. Like I said to you,
there will be but I don't want you to
fight. I don't don't jump from one point
to another point. I want you to focus on
yourself because when you die and your
family that love you so much, they'll
put you inside the grave, they will not
even spend one night with you. one
night. You seem like a smart guy. You
should think about it. Okay, if I die,
what will happen to me? Why there's
Islam? Why there's Christianity? Why
there's Judaism? All trying to get you
into everyone's trying to put you into a
religion. No, God. It's not us. It's
God. So you God gave you intellect. Like
for example, I never use a knife or or
any weapon to force you to become Muslim
or tell you except Islam. What I'm
doing, I'm I'm rationalizing, utilizing
our intellect to see which one makes
sense and which one is the religion that
came from God. Is it Christianity that
God became a baby? Someone say she's
nothing that can't be from God. No way.
You understand? Judaism is a tribal god
or or people that worship trees and the
monkeys and the pigs and the cows and
the trees. That cannot be how you
worship or that cannot be the true
followers of God. But Islam first is
Islam. Christianity to follow Christ.
Judaism to follow
Judah. Buddhism to follow Buddha. Islam
not to follow is not creating Muhammad.
What do I mean by that? Me is not
Muhammad. Islam means to submit to Allah
following the teaching prophet Muhammad.
We're not allowed to worship Prophet
Muhammad. Any Muslims that worship
prophet Muhammad will take him out of
world of Islam because prophet Muhammad
was a servant and the messenger of Allah
who came to teach us how to worship
Allah. You understand? So we look at
Islamic teaching. Look there's a huge
war against Islam especially on the
mainstream media. But the fastest
growing religion on the face of the
earth where is it?
Islam. Is Islam is spreading in the
west. Who's doing I want to go Dubai. I
want to go Dubai. You want to go Dubai?
Yeah.
Who's doing the job? Allah the most
high. Because Allah mentioned that in
the Quran 1,400 years ago that Allah
will make Islam spread even if a
disbelievers dislike it. And the prophet
Muhammad was taught us a prophecy. You
know, he prophesies about the future. He
said Islam will spread far east and far
west. And if you study Islamic history
where Islam mainly spread, it was far
east, far west. What about the end
times? The end times. What's the signs?
What's the signs? One of the signs of
the end time prophet Muhammad told us
interest will become widespread. AI and
stuff that's a sign is that
sign interest will become widespread.
You know it's interest the prophet
Muhammad who existed 1,4 years ago told
us interest will become
widespread. Now he said even if you are
not involved listen to this wording.
Yeah. He said even if you are not
involved directly will affect you. Now
by default if you open a bank account
even if you tell them listen I don't
want my money to be used for interest
they will still use your money for
interest wait step by step because stay
focused stay focused I know you're
getting excited I know you get excited
it's good to get excited I like that but
step by step me out the question before
you jump on you should ask yourself how
a man that existed 1,400 years ago is
able was able to prophesize about
something that we can see right How?
How? Because he's prophet of God. He's a
messenger of God. All right. Where's
your questions? What about um what about
Donald Trump? Him or Trump? You respect
him. Algeria. Yeah. Yeah.
You respect Donald Trump, huh? Donald
Trump. I don't respect his hood. I don't
respect his tyrants. I don't respect
him. You don't respect. He's a tyrant.
How can I respect him when you try to
kick out my people from
Gaza? I don't respect him. Yes. Muslim
countries they have relationship with
him because he's the leader of the
country. I don't respect him. I only
respect him in one thing. You know why
is that? He's an open enemy. He tell you
what he believes. You see also one thing
you have to respect him for even if it's
one thing that he's not allowing human
nature to be destroyed. You know like a
man is a man, woman is woman. It's true.
This is a reality. That's how God create
us. God create Adam and Eve. That's how
God create us. You know what means what
was Adam and Eve in Arabic? In the Quran
it's Adam saying and Arabic Eve you know
yeah there's many similarities in the
Old Testament like the Quran story of
Adam the story of Noah. However you can
see the stories in the Bible some of it
doesn't make any sense. You understand?
But before we move on so it makes sense
to you there is God now. Alhamdulillah.
So now we move on to the next step to
show you why Islam is the way of God.
Jesus, what was his belief? He died on
the cross. No, before we move on to die
on the cross, what was belief system?
Jewish.
Okay, I can't beg you a doubt. Show you
that if he was a Jewish or not.
According to the Old Testament, in order
for you to be a Jew or an Israelite, you
have it has to come from your father.
The father of Jesus had no father.
That's why he was a Jew. But he was
Israelite because he came from his
mother. Okay? But I'm saying what was
belief system? Jesus never called
himself a Christian. He never used the
word Christianity. The first time the
word Christian was used by Paul. What
would you believe? Muslim. What does it
mean Muslim? To submit yourself to God
according to God's
teaching. What was the belief system of
Moses? Moses was not a Jew. He never
said I'm a Judaism by the way. He was a
Jew background. You understand? Moses
submit himself to God according to God's
teaching. That's why the Quran it gives
you logical rational conclusion that
every every prophet and messenger who's
a Muslim meaning they submit themselves
to God according to God's teaching. You
understand? No, there's too tough Islam
to clarify is not lying to me. You can't
check I know him very well. Yes, there's
too tough Islam for you to understand
because I spoke to him before. I will
not speak to someone who supports
Netanyahu the Zionist, the murderer
terrorist. He was trying to justify and
defend Netanyahu. You understand? Anyone
that defend his terrorist, I don't I'm
gonna talk to him again. You're a man.
How old are you, brother? You were 20,
brother. I came to country by myself
when I was 16, bro. You understand? I
was a big man hustling. You understand,
brother? You You were 20. I saw God gave
you brain to take your own decision and
you get me. You know what I'm saying?
So, don't call him. If you want to come
discussion, I'm loving it. It's a night
discussion. You get me? If you don't
want it, then you can go and Yeah. Yeah.
What I'm saying to you, he does not
understand the meaning of Islam, there's
two type. There's a general Islam and a
specific Islam. General Islam means
every prophet and messenger and angels,
they are Muslims mean they submit
themselves to God. However, specific
Islam what prophet Muhammad came
with. That's why in the Quran, Allah
said
meant to Allah whatever upon the earth
and in the heaven submit to
Allah that's whatever they submit to
Allah. You understand Allah the
almighty. So what I'm saying to you I
gave you some prophecies about prophet
Muhammad prophesies about the future.
give you information. Who knows the
future in detail? No one except the most
high Allah God. You understand? So how a
man could I believe in Jesus? Well, he
prophesies. I believe in Moses. But let
me ask you this question. Would God
leave us with a corrupted teaching or he
will clarify the truth to us? Which one
is it? Clarify the truth to us. That's
why Prophet Muhammad was sent with the
Quran. The Quran has been preserved. You
know there's a verse in the Quran. Allah
said we have sent down the Quran and we
will preserve it. This is a claim that
the Quran will be preserved. We can put
it in a test in Africa, Asia, Europe,
America. If all the Muslims and the
Christians and the Jewish people came
together and says, you know what, let us
ban our scriptures. Let us get rid of
our scriptures. The only scripture will
remain with us is the Quran and we can
bring it back into the written form. You
know why? Because we have memorized it.
You see, we have hash and hashwash. You
see, so the So what about people that
are growing up Christian and their
family are Christian and they don't want
to move to be a Muslim. Okay, that's a
good question. Not if someone has been
raised in a Christian family like my
wife, my wife, she was a Christian.
Okay, she become Muslim when she was
very young, you know. However, if
someone was born as a Christian and he
dies and he never heard about Islam,
Allah will not punish him straight away.
Allah will test him because Allah is the
most
just. Allah is the most just. However,
if Islam was clarified to him and he
turned away from the truth, then don't
blame no one except yourself because
Allah is Allah is the most just. Allah
said Allah is the one to hold you
accountable because of your parents. But
Allah will hold you accountable of that
which are able to do. Allah never ask
you to change your skin color or your
nationality. Allah is asking you
something that you believe that you know
to change from the falsehood to the
truth. You understand? So Islam is based
upon justice. You understand?
Alhamdulillah. So one of the miracle of
Quran also Allah
said we have made we have made Quran
easy to be memorized. Now Africa, same
thing, Asia, America, Muslim at the age
of 9 and 10. Children, they don't know
Arabic language and they memorize the
Quran word for word and letter for
later. Imagine all of us here, we don't
know Chinese, but guess what? We
memorize a book in Chinese. What? How do
you think it's all going to end in terms
of judgment? Before we go to the end of
our last mess, you know what we doing
here? Let me clarify what we're doing.
Lay downation, put in the pillars,
ceiling, then we have a house. We'll get
there. We'll get there. Stay focused.
Then you go you can ask after which
curtain should we buy for the window.
All right. You know what I'm saying?
Asking the question that the curtain is
not the time for it now. What lamp you
want? Yes. So what I'm saying so far
does it make sense? Do you understand?
Like you know prophet Muhammad the
teaching of the Quran how the Quran has
been preserved like the Bible has been
corrupted. Jesus never spoke Greek,
never spoke English. He spoke what
language? What language? Huh? Arabic. No
no Arabic. No, he spoke some people
which is similar to Arabic called
Aramaic. All right, Aramaic or Syriak.
We don't have that language
anymore. So, we have translation and we
don't even know the
translators. You know, if we don't know
the translators, can we trust them? We
cannot trust them. But the Quran, we
memorized it. Even we have a written
form. Go back to the first century. But
we don't rely on the written form
because we have thousands of Muslim memo
the Quran by the Quran we have
it might be a long day which speak about
means reciting the Quran reciting the
Quran different ways and that's a
miracle of the Quran because the Arabs
there were different tribes they spoke
different ways they had different
dialects so how a man existed 1,400
years ago in the middle of desert was
able to know how the people of Hud
the people of Shem, the people of Syria,
the Arab in Syria, the Arab in Iraq, the
Arab in Yemen, how they spoke, the
dialect and the way that is a miracle
for the Quran to be different ways of
reciting it and all these different
recitation we call the Quran with
different recitation. So we
waiting to each other.
Yes. Back in those days they were
enemies to each other. And one of the
milk of the Quran, Prophet Muhammad
challenged the people to bring something
like it in its eloquency, legislation,
structure, the impact. However, no one
is able to bring something like the
Quran even though they wish the war and
guessing. You with me? You know what I'm
saying? So if you talk if it makes sense
to you what question you have question
so I have a question go ahead
just in terms of okay so in the Middle
East yeah the Middle East is mostly just
Muslim country Middle East is mostly
Muslim country
why is there war there so much war and
problems and everything like that that's
a good question that's a good
question but I just want to ask you I'm
Muslim okay and I supporting mah good
thank you but one thing why why and
Turkish people
killing support Turkish people we are no
Muslim I'm not
philanth it's haram it's haram talk
about it's haram we we have sometimes
the leaders for example Bashar is a
Syrian and he killed Syrians so why it's
haram killing Muslims helping Muslims
even killing innocent non-Muslims haram
haram is haram So this question I don't
know why you asking me for because this
question every Palestinian I don't
believe every Palestinian was supporting
the Turkish to kill
the I don't know about I'm a Palestinian
speak about it. Yeah, but let me finish
with
him. Let me finish with him then I'll
come to you. We
discuss as I was saying. So the Middle
Eastern countries Muslim Muslim. Yeah.
Why is it that there's so much war and
tension all the time? Why? That's
clearly you don't know. What about you
know about your history Cameron? Africa.
I know. I know. I know. Why there? Why
there is the word Africa? I'm not. So
why you ask me why? You know why? I'll
tell you why. Cuz the western world they
try to create this narrative that Africa
and Arabs they always backward fighting
each other and you as a black man from
Africa you f into the trap. Yeah. And
you need to be liberated. You need to be
liberated. You see you know what our
school
said. He said the worst type of slavery
is not when you've been enslaved by
someone else. When you are enslaved
mentally. That's right. You can be free
but if you are enslaved mentally it's
the worst type of slavery. You
understand? Cuz you enslaved. You just
don't know it. Yes. that yeah that's
what I'm saying that's why Islam came to
free people from slavery the true
slavery not become a slave of your
desires okay
so the point is about war before Israel
came into
existence was
stable before Iran came to to Iran Shia
took
over it was stable you understand and
even historically speaking it's known
The western world always try to to to
spread revolutions in Muslim countries
like was in Africa you understand cuz
they know we have a lot of resources in
our countries Africa look we have gold
but we poor Gaddafi Gafi Gafi was trying
to change that that's what I'm saying
Gaddafi always done it man Gaddafi
Gaddafi took out even he was he had some
problems there but he took care of his
children
okay now we talk about slavery so
slavery to refute this guy who was
support of the Zionist Who wants to kill
a Muslim children? Okay.
Slavery is before you don't like I don't
care. Yes. See what I'm saying? So So
even killing babies and
children. He's a liar. You're a
Christian. You're Christian. I'm not
Christian. He's a nationalist. He's a
blind follower. Let them try to So who
is the first man? Who is the first man?
Who the first Who is the first man?
Watch. Watch. He's going to answer me.
Who is the first man? Who is the first
man? Our first according to our
teachings, our first and the first of
all. There are two men twins. The twins.
The two women and twins. Female and
female. The male and the bro. I'm asking
you. This is why you can't get a solid
response. I understood what he said. He
said two twins. I'm saying male or
female.
Amar. Anyway, done. I'm done.
Who is it? The supreme the creator.
Prove that to me. Prove that to me. What
do you have to prove it to? Can you
prove everything that you see?
Everything is a
pro. That's it. So the difference
between him and I when I'm showing you
what is sorry you know when I start
showing you what Islam is a truth. I'm
giving you tangible proofs. Prophecies
that prophet Muhammad mentioned is
happening right now. The Quran that has
been preserved and you can test it.
Likewise the prophecies in the Quran him
will ask you for proof. He said that's
not a proof. You understand? That's what
differentiate Islam from any way of life
or religion. Islam is b is not based
upon emotions. I had a dream, prophet
Muhammad came to me. That's what Islam
is the truth. Islam is the truth because
it's based upon a clearcut proofs and
universal proofs. You understand? For
example, what are you talking about?
Going back to your question, say it's
about Israel. Isra came soal is came
they destabilize Arab countries. You
understand? But you guys like like
Palestine and you've been heavy
influenced by the western media.
Palestine Palestine Israel from from
Bible times
that no to stop. Yeah. But they stop the
time the when the Muslim roots when the
Muslims rule Palestine. There was no war
between the Muslims and the Jewish
people. Rather the the Christians they
were killing Jewish people in in Europe.
There were many Jewish people came to
our country Europe, Morocco, Algeria,
Tunisia, Turkey, Egypt. They came to us
seeking help from us. Why? Because the
Christians in Europe were killing the
Jewish people. But Jewish people when
God gave them a little power, look how
they turn. But I'm not I'm not
surprised. According to the Bible,
according to the Bible, they are known
to do that. They are known, the Jewish
people are known, not all of them, but a
lot of them, they are known to become
stubborn. Even they kill their own
prophets. Even they lie against God.
Even they try to kill who? Jesus. Our
beloved Messiah. They try to kill Jesus.
You understand? So we not say all of
them but a lot of them. So we Muslims
protect them. I'm not saying there were
non-Muslim leader that oppress some
Jewish people. But historically listen
to this. Yeah. Which many people don't
speak about it. Listen to this. Everyone
listen. Did you know that historically
speaking, Jewish people committed lot of
genocide but no one speaks about it.
Why? that according to the Bible, don't
call me anti samite because I'm a site.
I call me anti- myself. Likewise, if you
have a problem with my speech, you have
a problem with the Bible, you should ban
the Bible from teaching us this.
According to the Bible, the Malachites,
many nations, they're genocide, but no
one speaks about it.
You see what I'm saying? So, but when
you come to the Muslims, look, the
Muslims been oppressed. Instead of
standing standing with those who have
been oppressed, he's standing with the
oppressors. You know, I give you example
of Islam how teach me. Allah teaches me
even if you hate someone, don't lie
against him. Do not oppress him. And I'm
going to say every Muslim or Arab did
nothing wrong to the Africans. I can't
say that. No, I didn't say
that. There's some Arabs who oppressed
Africans. There's some Muslims oppressed
Africans. And there's Africans right now
killing the Muslims in Africa. Did you
know that central Africa African
Christians are killing the Muslims? Why
no one speaking about it?
Why no one is speaking about the Muslims
have been killed by the Christian
Africans in Central Africa? Yeah.
If no one's speaking about it, then it
probably isn't happening. No, it is
happening. It is must happen because we
can see who's controlling the media.
Those who control the media, those who
have hatred against Islam. Even still
Islam is the fastest growing religion on
the on the face of the earth. Even the
people who hate Islam they have more
power like material power. But Islam
remember Allah is all powerful. These
guys barking day and night and people
still accepted Islam. Allah Akbar you
know just just last just yesterday two
days ago one Christian lady became
Muslim. Last week one Jamaican brother
become Muslim. Alhamdulillah. Every
single day around the world, people
accepted Islam. Do you know who's doing
the job? Allah the
Almighty. Even when I'm speaking to you,
everything's logical. You have another
questions. Can I give you something to
read? But take it. This is a nice book.
It's a gift. Don't worry. There's not a
bomb in there. There's no weapon in
there. There's no knife. Maybe there's
some there's no instruction.
It's a good book. Read it. Use your
brain. If he makes sense, accept the
truth. If you say, you know what, it's
up to you. What's your name? Random.
Huh? Random. Brandon. You said random.
Brandon. Yeah. Brandon. I said random. I
said random. Brandon. Okay. Nice to meet
you, brother. Take care of yourself. I
pray when you go home as well, pray the
most high to die to the truth. All
right. Thank you very much. Make you.